Safety's off! Come on, push up!
Stormtroopers incoming!
In position!
Get down! Speeder bike!
Let's go, we're pushing them back!
Shield in place!
Some heavy fire, now!
Walker destroyed! Walker destroyed!
Look out!
Take cover! Look out!
We've got to call the bombers!
Take them out!
Y-Wings inbound.
That's it! Take cover!
Look out!
Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. So new Star Wars
Battlefront trailer just
revealed what we're gonna be blowing our
money on in November. And yes, it does have
DLC that will tie in with Episode 7.
So important stuff first. I know everyone wants to know, like, how is this gonna tie in with Episode 7 when
it's all Original Trilogy stuff in here,
like we see Darth Vader. Clearly he's
gonna be dead Episode 7.
Here's the deal. So the Episode 7 DLC
is gonna be the Battle
of Jakku, that's the new planet that
we're gonna see in Episode 7, the one with the
downed Star Destroyer here.
Connecting the dots you can surmise that
the Empire lost the battle, Star
Destroyer crashed on the planet.
The game itself is out November
17th, that's when you'll be able to play it.
If you pre-order the game you get access
to the DLC December 1st
but everybody else will get access to it December 8th so you'll be able to play it no matter what.
And it will be free content but you, I
mean obviously you have to buy the game to get it.
Once we get to the trailer I'll explain
what's going on with EA and games
based on the new trilogy.
So we start on Endor and like I said, you know, most of these maps are taken from the Original Trilogy.
For the most part the game's lifted from
the original Battlefront games so, you
know, if you really liked those you're
really gonna like this.
But EA married it to their new game engine
so it's an optimized experience for, like,
the new connected streaming HD world of
video games today.
Whenever the first Battlefront games
came out YouTube was a brand new thing.
Nowadays the social experience of games
has gotten really meta
so this just takes advantage of that. Even
though we're on Endor
I don't really know what the presence
of Ewoks is going to be. I imagine
they'll be in there somewhere.
There are a lot of things that they didn't
reveal, it's still not pre-alpha stage.
All the actual gameplay that they showed off
at Star Wars Celebration
is pre-alpha stuff so we can't post that
on YouTube yet. This is all taken from a PlayStation 4.
but the the actual character models will be
pretty close to this. We're in that age of game
play when the quality of cut scenes
and actual gameplay is getting closer and closer.
Speeder bike chase, very familiar. And
here's the big WTF, Darth Vader popping his lightsaber.
What's going to happen is Darth Vader
will be, like, an in game power up
available to players. They didn't really
announce what the specifics of that
are only that he will be available probably
with some other Original Trilogy
characters too based on which faction you're playing.
Here we are in another very familiar
place, this is planet Hoth. This X-Wing
canyon run is obviously from Tatooine.
If anybody remembers Rebel Assault they had, like, the
hardest canyon run in that game. I died
so many times. That was actually a DOS game,
who remembers that? Yay for nostalgia. Here's Boba Fett, one of the other power ups in the game.
I like the fact that there's a Jawa
Sandcrawler in the background just like
putzing along like no big deal.
These scenes are taken from the Imperial
shipyards on Sullust.
It's one of the bigger new locations that they
brought into the game. And yes, this will be
available when the game is released, it
won't be, like, DLC that you'll have to get later.
Yay for Millennium Falcon, another
power up in the game. A lot of the power ups
will probably also be based on which map you're playing.
So like I said you will still get that
Battle of Jakku DLC for free whenever the
game's released but if you want it a week
early you have to pre-order the game. They
haven't announced all their Special
Editions too but typically
they'll release like a Special Edition
with an artbook. That's pretty standard
operating procedure for, like, the really
big games nowadays.
Because it's EA though you probably
won't be able to buy it
in Steam, you'll probably have to buy it through
EA's servers if you want to buy digital download.
So now you're all asking, like, what's going
on with games based on the new trilogy,
Episodes 7, 8 and 9
because they're gonna be making
cartoons, all kinds of stuff for this new trilogy.
Of course they're going to be making video
games. Lucasfilm signed a 10-year deal
with EA to develop games based on
its IP so all the Star Wars games you
see for the next ten years will be
EA Games. This Star Wars Battlefront game
is actually part of the reason that they scrapped
the Star Wars 1313 project, that bounty
hunter Boba Fett game that they were
making that everyone loved so much.
As you can imagine Disney/Lucasfilm/EA
want to start off on a really strong
financial foot so they're going with the
franchise that they know fans will buy.
A lot of the big franchises chase trends
so you don't see them taking as many
chances with small indie games.
So for now most of the games will be
chasing, like, the really really big
titles like Destiny, Call of Duty,
you can imagine. I know everyone's hoping
for a new installment based on Jedi characters.
That will come but it's probably gonna take a
little bit. Typically games are released
during the Christmas shopping season.
All the Star Wars movies are gonna be
released in December
so every time a new Star Wars movie
comes out expect a new
really big game. So in related news, there's a
couple more videos that I'm working on
in the next day or two. There's a
new trailer for The Flash that's pretty crazy
so I'm gonna add that to my Flash and Arrow
Q&A. That'll be the next video that I post.
And I'll also talk about the Batman versus Superman leak. I know everyone wants to talk about that trailer.
I can't post anything about it just
because it's super illegal, like it's
getting pulled down all over the place.
Then I'll be working on some new
Daredevil so be sure to subscribe to get
all that stuff. I'm gonna try and get it all out
before Game of Thrones on Sunday.
So while you guys wait for all that stuff to
drop you can click here to rewatch
the Star Wars Episode 7 trailer three or four more times
and you can click here for all my Marvel videos.
Thank you so much watching. Everybody let's high-five.
I'll see you guys tonight.